I said I don't want to talk about it I
want to turn Megan back on while adults
are more developed in the brain and have
more of an ability to differentiate
between human and synthetic a child
doesn't possess that same understanding
which could be very dangerous and
harmful for her development again Megan
is a super stimulus she can do things
that no human can do and it's not
healthy for Katie to get attached to
that the most obvious example of this in
humans is with junk food junk food is
processed to contain intense flavors
that can be more stimulating to our
taste buds than natural unprocessed
Foods this stimulates the brain's reward
centers through the release of dopamine
causing overeating and unhealthy weight
gain combine that with aggressive
marketing and a low barrier for entry
AKA cheap prices and dollar menus and
you have a recipe for a very unhealthy
Society junk food harms your physical
health so Megan is essentially the
mental health equivalent she can say and
do all the right things to keep Katie
happy but what happens when you have to
turn her off Katie is unsatisfied with
her real human relationships and this
causes her to become ornery and
ultimately unhappy